thank you everything's great
life is good yeah has anything changed
since being married well I will say it's
definitely not just a piece of paper no
it really isn't you feel I don't know
it's it's amazing feeling hi I'm Denise
Richards and yep the rumors are true
just got married
Edie spoke with Richards at the hero dog
awards in Los Angeles where she talked
few rumors with fellow housewife to reek
Tinsley why are you upset now because we
are obsessed at the office we've seen
some photos surface of you and Doreen at
the wedding can you give us any comment
I don't know someone had said that we
heard you were fighting it was like no
she and then someone showed me the
picture and in that moment she was like
you're married and I'm like I know and
that and someone said we were anyway but
I love her she's amazing
just more an expression of concern just
happy we've got on good authority that
most of the housewives cast is at odds
with Lisa can you comment on that this
is my first season I say no bird the
actress also shared how happy she was
with the rest of the Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills cast when they showed
support at the premiere of her new film
toy box earlier this month
your housewives here as support for your
new movie how does it feel to have your
new friends here tonight it's nice I
love all of them they I do there's this
mean no catfights huh no catfights with
me they're so far they're they're really
strong women and very supportive of one
another and I really really admire that
in them and I love that they're here
it's very it means a lot have you gotten
used to the cameras following you around
all the time yet yeah it was a little
daunting when we go into restaurants and
stuff because I'm used to scripted where
there's extras and when we go in there
are no extras and we kind of make a
spectacle of us rock you can and then
when something happens that
that is crazy so it is very different
but I love it I'm having such a good
time I really enjoy them yeah
[Music]